stéphane rozès bonsoir merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors
peut-être un mot sur la forme un point
d'étape donc par le gouvernement
pourquoi finalement le gouvernement
tient à cette forme de communication
selon vous il avait été annoncée par le
président le gouvernement que tous les
quinze jours il y aurait un point
d'étape c'est absolument nécessaire à la
surprise du pays et sans goût des
gouvernants art confinement a été mis en
place le premier ministre castex mondial
c'était un confinement adapté c'est à
dire qu'il essaye de tenir un équilibre
entre la lutte contre la copie id est
néanmoins éviter un effondrement
économique et celle nécessite du coût
des points d'étape régulier pédagogique
car il faut des explications tant le
pays a été surpris y est et souffre même
si le confinement est adaptée notamment
des secteurs économiques sous donc il
était tout à fait nécessaire et nous
aurons un point d'étape soit la semaine
prochaine soit dans le quinze jours car
le premier mis ce cas ce texte a indiqué
des deux indicateurs circulation du
virus une pression sur le système
hospitalier qui ferait un allègement non
pas pour le dispositif le 1er décembre
annonciateur d'un allégement ou pas lors
de noël et du jour de l'homme alors plus
de contrôles de police pour faire
respecter le confinement a été annoncé
est ce que cette mesure pourrait être
davantage crisper les citoyens sont roux
crispé le terme est fort si derrière
vous entendez au fond des mouvements de
refus comme il peut exister dans
d'autres pays
je ne crois pas réellement il ya une
singularité française dans une plus
grande acceptation de normes nationales
al wallon pour tous à partir de critères
si les critères sont bien repéré c'est
la façon française liée à notre
imaginaire de mener la guerre contre la
pandémie
donc évidemment il y a énervement un
agacement mais je ne crois par bellion
les choses sont plus compliquées
évidemment pour les professions
d'indépendants de commerçants de monde
du spectacle ou pour eux alors qu'il
pensait que le plus dur était passé à
nouveau pour beaucoup d'entre eux il ya
une question de survie économique le
premier ministre à ce texte a indiqué
que des mesures seraient prises en
termes d'accompagnement économique mais
ce sont vraiment ces catégories da qui
souffrent beaucoup
alors autres dossiers abordés à la
fermeture des lycées des collèges
finalement écartée au profit d'un
durcissement du protocole sanitaire qui
va être annoncé par jean michel blanc
terre le gouvernement il a raison de
tenir sa ligne sur l'ouverture des
écoles je dois faire preuve comme nous
tous d'une grande modestie tellement
quant au jugement
tellement les choses sont des cas qu'à
partir du moment où les ressources ce
qui d'ailleurs sont ce qu'elles sont
s'il y avait une critique à l'égard des
gouvernants c'est plutôt l'état du
système hospitalier le fait contre les
deux vagues des mesures n'ait pas été
prise à la hauteur de ce qu'on aurait pu
redouter stadion deuxième vague ce qui
n'était pas le cas pour les uns des
autres mais gouverner c'est prévoir mais
maintenant on est face à la difficulté
face à cette deuxième vague dont le
premier muscat ce texte a dit qu'elle
était extrêmement forte
comme chez nos voisins d'ailleurs tout
est question effectivement d'arbitrage
on le sait ce parmi des usagers de
d'école et notamment les enseignants il
y avait des mises en garde sur le fait
que selon eux les mesures sanitaires
n'étaient pas à l'école respecter
donc effectivement vous l'avez dit vas y
avoir des aménagements encore plus
important la matière mais kelly la
difficulté la difficulté c'est pas
seulement le désoeuvrement oisiveté de
nos jeunes ou l'articulation entre le
fait que les jeunes soient pris en
charge par le système éducatif de sorte
que leurs parents salariés soit libéré
pour pouvoir travailler et alléger les
conditions du confinement c'est
également le fait que toute une classe
de jeunes scolarisés sont objectivement
terriblement pénalisés dans leur
capacité dans dans ce qu est un droit
pour les jeunes futurs citoyens et
salariés d'avoir accès à la connaissance
à la pédagogie et donc la longueur du
premier confinement plus second confirme
en fait qu' il y a un retard qui se
creuse terriblement pour nos jeunes et
notamment
il ne faut pas s'illusionner sur les
catégories populaires au fond les
classes moyennes classes supérieures
dont toujours des moyens d'aider leurs
enfants
que ça soit par les ressources
familiales ou périscolaires ou les
petits courts ou des choses comme ça
nous les accompagnements diverses et
variées
la difficulté ce sont la situation pour
les catégories populaires dont les
parents travaillent souvent dans des
conditions plus difficiles avec moins de
t&d travail et puis qui ont des
ressources culturelles par la force des
choses moins importante donc je
comprends tout à fait le fait que autant
faire se peut selon les règles
sanitaires puisse être maintenue l'école
pour nous enfants merci beaucoup
stéphane rozès d'avoir réagi à la prise
de parole de jean castex